Short while ago,
I had the honor of talking with Ian
Hirsi Ali,
who I regard as a genuine modern day
heroin and a role model for all
individuals who desire to speak and
embodied the truth.
I'll tell you a little bit about her
before the discussion starts.
Ali Born in 1969 as a Somali Dutch
American author and scholar.
She's received international attention
as a critic of Islam and an advocate for
the rights and self determination of
Muslim woman opposing honor violence,
arranged marriage from which she escaped
by immigrating from Somalia and female
genital mutilation,
to which she was subject as a child.
She's a fellow at Stanford's Hoover
Institution and Harvard's Kennedy
School,
a visiting scholar at the American
Enterprise Institute in Washington DC,
and a member of the council on Foreign
Relations.
She founded the Ion Hirsi Ali Foundation
explicitly for the defense of women's
rights in 2003 Hirsi.
Ali was elected to the lower house of
the Dutch House of Representatives,
a political crisis related to her Dutch
citizenship led to her resignation and
indirectly to the fall of the second
Balkan end.
Cabinet did not.
In 2006,
a former devout Muslim Hirsi Ali left
the faith and became a vocal critic of
Islam,
particularly in radical forums.
She collaborated on a short movie with
Theo van Gogh in 2004 entitled
submission.
The film depicted the oppression of
women under fundamentalist Islamic law,
sparking controversy and threats of
death.
Van Gogh was in fact stabbed to death by
Mohammed booberry,
a Moroccan Dutch Islamic terrorists
later that year,
Hirsi Ali maintains that quote,
Islam is part religion and part a
political military doctrine.
The part that is a political doctrine
contains a worldview,
a system of laws,
and a moral code that is totally
incompatible with our constitution,
our laws,
and our way of life.
Her best and influential books include
the caged virgin 2004,
infidel,
2006 no mad,
2010 and most recently heretic 2015
where she calls for a reef formation of
Islam and the defeat of the Islamists in
2005 Hirsi.
Ali was named as one of Time Magazine's
100 most influential people in the
world.
She's also received a free speech award
from the Danish newspaper,
Yellen's posting the Swedish Liberal
Party's democracy prize and the moral
courage award.
Her critics accused Ellie of building
her career on the denigration of Islam
and Muslims questioning her right to
authoritatively about Islam and the Arab
world,
and portraying her as the embodiment of
the western colonial civilizing mission
discourse.
I guess you'll be able to render
judgment on that yourself.
After watching our discussion.
The first thing I'd like to say is,
thank you very much for agreeing to do
this video.
I'm very happy to be talking to you.
I'd be nervous about it all day
actually.
Oh,
well,
anything?
No,
she tells me to do.
I see,
I see.
Okay.
So,
well,
I sent you some,
some questions the other day and I
thought that I would first of all ask
you,
I read your,
your recent paper,
the one that you wrote for the Hoover
Institute called the challenge of Dawa.
Yes.
And so I thought maybe I'd ask you if
you would,
to begin with just to tell people if you
could give them a brief summary of what
you were attempting to accomplish with
that.
That might be a good way to start.
So what I was trying to accomplish was
to get the attention.
Oh,
I also say,
especially if the government,
uh,
to the ideology that underlie this,
the alphabet tentative thing,
the misogyny against women,
homophobia by Islam is to eliminate all
homosexuals,
again,
increase in antisemitism,
the persecuted Christians
guys like me who are ex Muslims and draw
attention to the venues where these
ideas are disseminated to these schools.
It's in the mosque them address that.
It's in the neighborhood and it's a
photo to use.
Sometimes it's these professionals who
say that they asked you a large gates
for telling young people as young as age
how to hate and hate.
And once we understand,
once we understand these commitments to
get into the heads and across people,
the ideas with radical Islam that I fit
it in,
they'll be able to do with the tenor of
the outcomes of the call.
Radical Islam is an extension of doubt.
That's what I'd like to see it as an
extension of and for me to have
constitutes the violence,
the terrorist attacks and the political
violence it's used to make that's
intended to change.
Society will be able to
eliminate,
to eliminate eliminated.
Okay,
so what exactly would you say is the
relationship between Darwin and Jihad?
You're formulating it by the sounds of
it that Darwin is the to Jihad and these
are the concepts reasonably separable
and I guess a subsidiary question with
that would be we're talking about
radical Islam,
but of course many of the people who are
watching are going to be.
It's going to be difficult for them to
distinguish between moderate Islam and
radical Islam and I'm also curious about
your feelings about exactly that
distinction and how such a thing might
be pursued.
So my approach to it is there is one
Islam,
but there are three sets of most
letters.
There's one Islam and that one is land.
It's of different components.
It has religious components,
it has a political component,
a social component,
but it's all encompassing.
Now,
if you look at the different sets of
Muslims,
what you see is one set of Muslims,
we just here to the religious
prescriptions and they see being a
Muslim as something private
and when they're confronted by others
about the political activist,
other bad things that other Muslims who
they involved with the Koran and the
Prophet Muhammad who is the founder of
Islam by mentioning of his life in the
early days when he first started with
this religion and sway people and using,
but then there's the other set of
Muslims I called them.
Then the Dean's list,
the other ones who they're the ones that
engage in Dallas.
They're the ones who have the objective
of viewing the world.
Who is the other ones to hate
homosexuals.
To date,
women who hate Muslims tend to say that
it's their duty to die.
Converse with people.
It's not,
I call it the Medina Muslims because
they invoke the prophet Muhammad's life
and example,
and the legacy in Medina.
I called the modifiers.
These are limbs could sending up to the
Medina,
Muslims within Islam.
As a civilization,
as a culture,
as a political philosophy,
we have a theological problem and we
have to deal in theological problem.
So these are for me,
these are the three different sets of
Muslims,
the problem of the Medina Muslims,
the other ones were engaged in your work
to differentiate between what's in the
dino Muslims to Israel and the
attendant.
And why don't we first start with
Dallas.
We've called you to this love and if you
reject it,
then you are an enemy of his love and
use violence in their circular.
They're good arguments.
Why should we or Islamic law was good
for you,
for women and Muslims?
Uh,
this is what is in the club.
This is what Muhammad said,
informing anything confused and this,
this fall to persuade,
to,
to buy it.
Then they apply for.
And that was the reputation of course
better,
but you have been for the Muslims,
but there's to convinced non Muslims
from that,
for that status.
There's this other project,
status of purgatory.
You know,
where you have to pay discriminatory
taxes and lead a life of second class
citizens.
If you look at the Christians who live
in Egypt,
Christmas,
who live in Pakistan,
patients who live in the majority of
countries,
it's that kind of status.
So,
so the Mecca Medina distinction seems to
be very,
I would say both complicated and
problematic because.
So,
so tell me if I'm wrong.
Okay.
Because my understanding is that
Mohammed spent most of the part of his
life that was associated with the
establishment of Islam in Medina and
noting that guy and that it wasn't until
he went to Medina,
that Islam actually became a force.
So back in Mecca,
although his doctrine appears to have
been,
let's say,
more peaceful.
It was also much less successful as a,
as a,
both a religious and a political
movement.
So then he left Mecca and I believe
under pressure from the inhabitants,
at least to some degree,
moved to Medina.
And then that's when Islam became more,
uh,
more,
more revolutionary and expansive.
And so what do you see now?
I know that it isn't universally
accepted among the Islamic community
that,
that Mecca Medina distinction is a
reasonable one to make.
Because of course,
the presumption is that there's an
essential unity of thought across the
doctrines,
but,
but given,
given your interpretation,
and I've read the similar interpretation
among other,
among other people,
do you see,
what do you see as hopeful within the
Islamic community with regards to
bridging the gap between the say the
earlier works,
so to speak of Mohammed and the later,
the later,
more,
more revolutionary element of the,
of his actions and his faith.
Is there a way that that can be
reconciled?
Do Muslims into Mecca,
Mecca,
Medina,
and modifiers.
That's not,
of course an official,
a distinction not accepted anywhere you
really wanted to get to,
you know,
who,
which individuals,
which Muslims,
uh,
at war with us.
And should we be worried about what
about the vasculature?
What about these other Muslims who are
speaking up labels?
We will give him,
if you said the word Islam most work.
One thing that I noticed is that
selected and we justified it.
I actually,
they invoke method.
Oh,
Mohammed's legacy in Mecca.
Because as unfortunately if my sister
tells me,
Oh yeah,
and you've listed there,
you need to get up and say I want to
invoke some best for my parents,
say,
oh,
come on my relationship with intimate
and then make it your business to tell
him what to do,
and then she would come up with some
other ideas or some other,
but it's my duty to come in and go,
so this limit,
but then it's the Medina Muslims extent
and I'm not the only one that other
scholars like.
There are many others who have
preserving a position as a culture,
as a civilization,
and at the same time putting this
violence and providing courses within
Islam.
If you're trying to do that,
then you'll go to see your way to make a
list of all the concepts that we really
don't have any problem with.
People being told to pay five times.
This is letter of cost in the market and
also they just don't have a problem with
all of that data that's been referenced
to the early days in Medina.
As you said,
a political philosophy.
Mohammed,
we just wars because he would spend and
that's exactly where was successful and
that Islam is to end and they say,
listen,
to be,
you know,
it could be emulating.
So that's I think where the public
market that we apply in the social
sciences has its problems,
but this simplifies because it focuses,
it should work.
Okay.
So you see this as an externally
applied,
um,
uh,
a category system essentially that
that's useful,
that's useful for,
for,
for outsiders who were trying to assess
the situation to determine who it is
that you're dealing with that might be
regarded as an ally and who it is that
you're dealing with.
It might be regarded as a fold,
so to speak,
and that would be on the more militant,
tend to have things that,
that,
that's a reasonable way of looking at
it.
That's reasonable.
That's a reasonable way of looking at
it.
But if you take
the moderates versus extreme
classification or categorization,
that has become common place.
It doesn't tell you what,
when we look at model,
we think of people who are not using
violence.
Whereas if you look at Medina,
you will see that there are hundreds of
thousands of Muslims who do not apply
violence now,
but who do preach about this and they do
preach the Medina legacies and they
leave that Sharia should be instituted
and in places where they get where you
get a majority of these violent and
ideally types,
then suddenly they apply and forces
Sharia alone.
So I think the terms model is an extreme
are just not good enough.
They don't cover.
They also seem to bear any relationship
to the internal dynamics of the faith
itself.
So whatever.
That's also problematic.
Okay.
So does that because you have to keep
going back to the theology.
You have to keep going back to the
internal debate among Muslims,
how to move on and how to relate to the
test.
So I personally think Mecca and Medina
is much more useful as a tool,
as an external conceptual framework for
understanding the problem we face with
Islam.
Then extreme versus freshwater and all
the,
you know,
all the other terms that we have.
So let me ask you another question about
that then.
So see,
one of the problems that I've had
[inaudible] I've been trying to look at,
at the potential for true relationship
between Islam and Christianity,
you know,
to the degree that I understand Islam or
Christianity,
which of course there's plenty to
understand about both,
so it's no easy thing to manage,
but there is this claim as well that,
that that's widespread and rather vague
that,
that Islam is in essence a religion of
peace.
And,
but when I look at the historical data,
say stemming from Medina,
the Medina time,
and then moving forward and the fact
that that Mohammed was definitely
someone who engaged personally in
warfare and in expansionist warfare,
it's not,
it's not an easy thing for me to make
the leap to,
uh,
to see comprehending or being able to
accept the claim that the fundamental
doctrines of Islam are peaceful,
are,
are associated with peace.
Because it looks to me like there's an
element of it that's quite militaristic.
And I've also thought that let's say
there's a religious element to Islam.
And I mean this is not an original
thought.
Obviously there's a religious element to
Islam,
but there's also something that's
clearly more like a political movement
and more like a governmental movement
and that's also complicated by the fact
that there isn't any clear separation
between church and state in Islamic
doctrine as far as I can tell,
so when we hear claims that are,
when claims are made that Islam is
essentially a religion of peace,
then that doesn't seem to be the case
with Medina,
end of the theological discourse or the
actions that that emerged there of and
then part of the problem is how do you
reconcile that with the contradictions
in relationship to the earlier,
earlier,
as you say,
Meccan doctrines and it isn't clear to
me how that can be done so
as a political force obligated to
enforce it.
So number one,
they did not give have his message.
You guys are worshiping false gods,
these that you live in a time and I'd
like to and come work with.
You know what,
these peaceful,
peaceful.
It's because he applied for.
Didn't personally.
Do you have an attacker describe
ourselves in Levina then?
He does.
That was in the war and the numbers with
Muslims and these are people who come
from with them by then.
Then the says everywhere,
wherever that is,
destination is only after you accept
Islam as long as you refuse to abide by
Islamic law or accept to be subdued by
Islam,
you are at war.
That's why they.
The Medina is make this distinction
between the house of Islam piece and the
horrors of war is everywhere where
they're introduced and it's the job of
the Muslims in the house feed to
congrats.
So it's a religion of peace in so far as
it's final utopian aim is the cessation
of conflict,
but it's the cessation of conflict in
part as a consequence of of conquests.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well that was more or less how I
understood it.
So when the claim is made that it's a
religion of peace,
then that isn't precisely.
It's a slight of hand in some sense.
With regards specifically to that phrase
that are individuals.
That was I skype as maker will say when
they say what they really wanted to say,
peaceful individual,
no problems with other religions and I
want to be engaged with any politics or
to link politics with religion please.
Right,
right,
right.
And that I wouldn't say it wouldn't be
the majority of Muslims worldwide.
I'm not sure you agree with that,
but it seems to me that it isn't self
evidently the case that the majority of
human beings are violent and war like
and so my sense is is that given the
essential peace peacefulness of most
people,
they're going to take a look at the
Islamic doctrine and extract from it
those elements that are supportive of
that more individual pace,
but that still leaves open the question
of exactly what the doctrine means as a
set of motivational principles and now
it seems to be a big part of the current
problem and also the need for current
discourse.
What I would hope is that it would be
possible to undertake a dialogue with
Islam.
Let's say between Islam and the West are
between Islam and Judeo Christianity and
defined within Islam itself.
The seeds that would enable that
dialogue to occur so that some sort of
long term negotiated conceptual and
practical piece could be attained,
but the more I've read about Islam,
the more difficult it is for me to
understand how that might be managed,
especially because of it's because of
the war like tradition that emerged from
from Medina and then move outward in at
a staggering rate from that and also the
thing that's quite quite disconcerting
to me.
I mean it's not like Christianity hasn't
been rife with internal divisions like
that between the steps and the
Catholics,
but it also was the case that what you
might describe as the civil war that's
been occurring within Islam,
more or less started as far as I can
tell,
more or less started that day that
Mohammed died and has never stopped
since that and that also seems to be.
Well obviously it's a problem for the
Islamic community itself,
but it also seems to be a problem,
an increasing problem for the west
because we can't not be tangled up in
that.
Yeah.
We we have to share the planet with one
fifth of humanity and it's very clear
that things have to change and that's is
the beauty of Muslims to change the
theological underpinnings of their
religion and as far as I'm concerned,
this is being pushed by those that I
call the farmers or modifies and these
are individuals maybe now a little
bigger groups are forming views and
maybe even being led by some nation
state for that.
The big question is either going to
agree on what to change.
So what is in built into Islam is this
idea that you.
I'm submit edits to the Koran and it's
the same thing.
You know,
Mohammed was a by Muslims as infallible
as somebody who never made a mistake.
So it's an uphill battle for those
Muslims who are seeking modernization to
agree on,
you know,
how to edit,
how to persuade Muslims to accept a
truly peaceful right.
And a truly tolerant idea of religion
that separates religion from politics,
respects the rights of women or people
of other faiths and people within Islam
who voted to leave their faith.
So how do you get the theological
underpinnings for that?
Yeah,
that's within his lap.
The danger there too is that when that
sort of thing is attempted,
often reformed from within a religious
community,
one of the dangers there is that instead
of reforming it peacefully,
all you do is add another sect to the
court.
Yeah.
For us secular people,
it seems from from a distance it seems
kind of easy to say,
well why don't they just separate
religion from politics and to they just,
they can be religious to look at it that
way.
Simplistic.
Because then you get people who want to
be religious.
These Medina subset,
what do you say for Medina was an
expression of his muslimness is to
convert to Islam to kill me as opposed
to if it's to get women to cover up,
it's to keep warning us about life life
today and all of that.
It.
It's the thing that made me,
I wouldn't say nervous to some degree
from the perspective of someone who
analyzes totalitarian ideology because
the thing about totalitarian ideology is
it tends to be totalitarian,
right?
It's absolutely all consuming and that's
why also when I've been assessing,
because I've done a fair bit of research
into comparative religion and done my
best to expand my knowledge base and
I've always had a hard time with Islam
in that regard because it's difficult
for me to extract out the purely
religious elements and to compare them
to let's say religious sentiments that
have emerged across across humankind and
all sorts of different times and arrows
and to separate that from the political
doctrine and sometimes I'm tempted to
think more that Islam,
you know,
broadly and vaguely speaking,
is something much more like a political
movement than it is in fact like a
religious movement.
It is a political theory and it's a
political movement.
It started out even in Mecca in the
early days come to my board,
which was a political message.
It wasn't a religious message,
right?
Even in the early days in it was
absolute is Islam by its nature is
absolutely just because it a complete
and total submission of the individual
to God and in Medina.
Mohammed came around with a political,
a blueprint for how society ought to
live,
the relationship between the individual
and the relationship between men and
women,
husband and wife,
the relationship between parent and
child,
the relationship between the government
and the subjects and their duties.
It has a court system.
It has a military system,
so from the very beginning it was more
political theory.
As we understand the agent today,
Jesus Christ founded his religion within
an empire.
The Roman empire existed before and what
he was talking about was all religions.
Mohammed,
we forget.
Yeah,
yes,
right.
That's a very important distinction.
I mean really,
and it might be the crucial distinction,
so to speak,
and there was this empire,
empire bows and decline and fell and
those who feel that they have inherited
that legacy.
They want to go back to the days of
employment for about 20 days when Islam
was supremely and they want to do this
in the 21st century.
All kinds.
It's not just.
You can't come on horseback and inmate
and existing client like the Indian
empire that they took over.
You could just take things also.
It's not like la,
but they're driven,
they're convinced they have this legacy
and they're not afraid of it and is key
because,
and here's why I keep going back to that
life on this temporal and that there is
something in the after this.
There's no point in investing in this
life accepting that nature,
so for the Medina Muslims,
it really becomes easy to recruit and
inspire into their parents' Muslims who
have already been taught that they've
only got to work for the hereafter
problems with Islam and I think it was
would understand of course the basic lms
of Mohammed Straw with all of the Koran
before all of the heat,
after all of these things and what
Sharia law really means,
and then it gets to the past.
This is how they managed to teach young
people.
How do they manage to teachable or these
thousands and millions of people who is
subsidizing this countries like Saudi
Arabia,
Qatar,
etc.
Understand that.
I think that makes oUr job as western
whatever's easiest.
Let's talk about the saudis for a
minute.
The elephant under the western carpet.
I mean,
I understand that in the aftermath of
the oil crisis in the 19 seventies,
one of the things that that dictated
american foreign policy was the desire
to maintain stable oil production and
and I can understand that although I
think it was short sighted,
I can.
I can see the logic in that,
but it's very difficult for me to see
that in any possible way.
The saudis can be regarded as true
allies of the west and so I don't
understand why we have the relationship
that we do have with the saudis given.
First of all,
they were pumping literally trillions of
dollars every about every decade into
the economy and then given that they
practice a particularly pernicious form
of,
I would say viciously militant islam and
second or third,
I guess that is that they're pumping out
propaganda that pushes this wahhabi
viewpoint in massive doses everywhere in
the world.
I mean,
I don't understand,
and maybe this is also part of the
complexity with regards to western
attitudes towards,
towards the complex problem of islam.
I don't understand why the west doesn't
do more to put a stop to that.
And so what are your thoughts about
that?
How does it look to you?
I'm perplexed.
I believe that the south would have
booked the United States and other
western business under this.
Someone has to come along and break
that.
Uh,
I,
it,
I mean,
I agree with everything you said within
Saudi Arabia,
I believe at least three forces,
the royal family who I believe now
sexier and more modern,
they want to go down the larger,
incredibly powerful,
maybe even more powerful than the oil
because the clergy in Saudi Arabia,
they have the power to put into people's
heads and hearts the wahhabi doctrine.
And so it's all about Saudi Arabia here.
People who decide what's right or what's
wrong,
moral other time,
right?
They have that powerful and then you
have the trach,
the various stripes who obviously
depending on their size of royal family
or the clergy or both.
There's a dynamic there that is very
interesting to watch,
but in that sense,
Saudi Arabia has used and has indulged
as larger established legacy Saudi
Arabia.
People medina inside the borders of
Saudi Arabia and tyler.
Yup,
and now I think we the United States and
other countries who need to be mad from
the saudi royal family because they are
the ones who are political,
at least the political individuals that
we did with tj and say we need a
different between the house and the
house of will happen because these
people are really destroyed.
The planet vape.
You just said you have to think through
what these people have done in south
asia,
in africa,
all over the world.
It's the duty of a part of it swells to
discredit this lab,
this lab that is through institutions
and this is.
This is therefore policies.
we probably could refer that to a soft
power.
That's where the cloud,
but that if you look at what is
happening,
all these terrorist activities across
the people wanting sheree about all of
soda really is behind it and I think
staying with that.
Yeah.
Okay,
so let me run a theory by you.
It's kind of a twofold theory.
So one is that there's a paternalistic
attitude in the west towards the saudis
that stems from perhaps events that were
as far back as 100 years ago,
and the paternalistic aspect is to
underestimate them as enemies,
right?
Because you say,
well,
we could say,
well we need the oil and we're going to
stabilize it and maybe that we'd rather
not have chaos in Saudi Arabia.
And so unknown dictator is better than
unknown chaos and we saw some proof of
that perhaps in what happened with
Libya,
but so the idea would be there's nothing
sufficiently dangerous about the saudis
to justify us destabilizing their
regime,
especially when we're particularly
dependent on their oil.
And then underneath that would be an
underestimation of the danger of ideas.
And also,
especially when ideas are combined with
money.
It's something like that.
So because the saudis in some sense I
think are are fighting what you might
regard as a stealth war against the weSt
and they're doing it by convincing
upcoming generations of the rightness of
their particular viewpoint.
And so they're in it for the long haul
in some sense.
And I think we're radically
underestimating the danger of that and
it's quite logical law and we're not.
Yeah,
we're not.
I mean you have to think when the soviet
union was around,
if we hadn't done anything interest was
viewed that in economic terms for in
military terms and that is not just
telling rabia is even Iran,
these countries are waging an
ideological war and we're not because
they believe,
well it's religion.
Religion is proTected and we don't talk
about religion.
And that's one thing we believe we're
under the spell of these incredibly
charming.
So that's come to attend our
universities that have the emphasis and
that reassure us that they're more
westernized than we can tell them how
they treat their women.
So in a way I think,
again,
I just keep going back and say we are
under some sort of spell and at some
point someone has to come and break that
spell globalization to,
you know,
a Saudi Arabia opens up to the world
economy.
We really see what was on Inside their
own country and inside all of these
other countries.
It's the people,
the canadian people,
western people pushes.
And say no to and the amount from their
documents that they engage with Saudi
Arabia in a different way.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the thIngs I really can't figure
out,
maybe you could shed some light on this
too,
is that you know,
of all the things that women's political
movements should be doing in the west is
demanding as far as I can tell that the
western countries,
let's say lead by their male rulers,
stop treating the saudis like are there
are allies and I cannot understand why
there hasn't been a concerted pressure
put on western governments by women who
are concerned,
at least in principle with the equality
and freedom of women around the world to
stop treating the saudis like they're
our allies.
And so that,
that's another thing that perplexes me
entirely in the cynical part of me
thinks that the feminists who are more
or less hell bent on the destruction of
the western patriarchy adopt the
attitude that the enemy of my enemy is
my friend.
And so they're willing to put up with
what the saudis do.
But I don't think that's a sufficient
explanation.
So I mean you can view our,
our culture,
so to speak a little bit from,
from the outside position because you
haven't moved in as an immigrant and
that gives you a viewpoint that it's
much more difficult for someone within
it to share.
And so like what do you see as as
driving the absence of pressure,
let's say from women on governments in
relationship to these,
I would say reprehensible dictatorships.
What's going on?
So the pre occupied with western country
after,
with what I see is that they have a
festival that's focused only.
They do not talk about,
discuss the issue of a man of color and
the patriarchy.
Men of color or immigrants of the
nations and countries,
man,
nations and countries outside.
Oh the feminist to the identity politics
there was on multiculturalism and all
these things are bad for women,
western women and bad.
So if you believe take multiculturalism
is that so and the fasteners one since
then they feel that they use to address
greAt belief that black women and muslim
women,
you know,
women of color,
if they wanted to get out of oppression,
then they should organize themselves.
That's what they believe.
What I find ironic is that sometimes we
do organize ourselves.
I am organized another ex muslim woman
to talk about the misogyny that's
subjected to women in the white,
white feminist,
atheist.
And that's the biggest puzzle
I know.
Well,
I think that the treatment that you've
received at the hands of western
feminists,
to me that's,
that's something that's just absolutely
it me absolutely speechless because
not only me,
it's all of us.
Again,
like I could fall to excellence,
but there are black women who are
fighting for their rights and they all
get shut down.
So we were talking about your treatment
at the hands,
let's say a western feminists and,
and like I read infidel,
I don't know,
very shortly after you published it,
which I love that book man.
As soon as I read that,
I thought,
well,
I used which hell yeah,
you know,
I thought it was remarkable.
I thought your comment on your comments
on viewing western culture from the
perspective of an immigrant that was
hungry for,
for genuine education and,
and your comments on your,
your experience with the efficiency of
the dutch state say,
and you're sort of amazement at how well
it worked.
That was just.
I thought that was so remarkable and
clearheaded and I thought when I read
infidel,
I thought,
well this woman is immediately going to
be a hero to feminists everywhere
because she's removed yourself from this
oppressive state and moved out into the
world and become a powerful figure when.
What was the probability of that?
It was like zero,
you know,
and that you suffered as a consequence
of your beliefs and,
and you stood up forthrightly for them
and I thought if you wanted to find a
feminist hero that you are certainly,
you're certainly in the running man for
exactly that.
And then to see how you've been treated.
It's just,
I just,
it just makes my jaw drop,
you know?
Especially what brandeis did was
brandeis right where you were offered an
honorary phd and then they revoked it.
That just.
That was one of the.
I think that was almost as
reprehensible,
inactive cowardice as the west's basic
abandonment of solomon rushdie after the
fat,
what was put on his head and about
equally dangerous,
so it was multicultural.
I mean what I,
you know,
my message,
my lifestyle and who I am,
it said they find off the prevalent
today.
It's against the law
that western values as superior to
islamic law and islamic values.
Not to say that is to blast being in the
temples of multiculturalism today.
I think
I,
I hope a lot of people because it wasn't
about what they think should happen for
victims of misogyny.
I think it's all about the disciplines
that my wife's and my,
my lIfe and my beliefs kind of
dissonance.
They put these women in.
Because if you're going to say,
well,
it's horrible to be an american woman,
and the misogyny in America is worse
than that.
They say,
no,
It's not.
I'm sort of interfering with their,
with their worldview.
The claim that you're making there is
something like this and it's really,
it's a really vicious claim in a sense,
and it's something like the western
feminists who are possessed by
postmodernism and cultural relativism
are willing to sacrifice the freedom and
equality of third world women in places
like Saudi Arabia to maintain the
sanctity of their multicultural notion
because that justifies their attack on
western patriarchy,
so they're willing to use.
Okay,
so that that's an absolutely
immigration.
There are so many men who are coming
from these societies as men.
They are not used to the equality of
women inside the west.
First of all,
they're all women,
child marriages,
female genital mutilation,
honor killings,
but now we have these crepes and sexual
harassment of non muslim women and women
keep on arguing for more integration and
they don't hear anything negative about
some of the negative impacts of
immigration.
I don't consider them feminists anyhow.
I think that there are so much more
committed to preserving their world view
their postmodern as well than they are
to the rights of women and they're mean.
I think that that's how it looks to me
is like this situation with Saudi Arabia
is the one is the test case is like,
so you might say,
are the postmodern feminists types are
the ones who present themselves as.
Are they more concerned with the rights
of women or are they more concerned with
bringing down the so called tyranny of
the west and the answer is they're more
concerned with the louder than they are
with the farmer because when you put
them head to head,
they dispense with the rights of women
across the world as long as they can
maintain their moral justification for
the radical beliefs and I do think that
is why they go after you because you're.
You're exacTly the reprehenSible
exemplar of what it is that they're
attempting to deny.
I would say,
and I think that does show their true
motivations
absolutely.
Out at the time.
I'm guessing a lot of signals here that
I should.
I should hang up now,
but I really enjoyed talking to you and
I hope that in some way I've contributed
to,
to the message that she wants to get out
there.
You know what,
I'll start with this,
I'll give you 30 seconds.
I'll just tell you what,
what are doing with this,
I mean I have arranged with a group of
moderate muslims in Canada and some in
the us as well to start a series of
dialogues like the one that we had today
because this isn't really viciously
important problem and so I want to use
this as the opener for that.
I would like to go after this issue of
whether or not a real dialogue could be
begun between the judeo Christian West
and the islam world with some hope of
not having all of this evolved into
endless and continual warfare because as
far as I can tell,
that's where it's headed.
Yes.
That's where it's headed.
Yeah.
Well go get a chance to talk again.
Thank you so much.
Yep.
Bye bye.